[Music]
okay for your postgres workloads how can
you use cloud SQL and ledb for postgres
well both are managed database services
in Google cloud cloud SQL is manage
postgres and ledb is fully postgres
compatible Cloud sql's Innovative
features make it a strong choice for
anyone wanting a postgres service in the
cloud and alloy db2 its database engine
delivers High availability and increased
performance speaking of performance
Cloud sql's performance will match most
of your workload needs since it
shouldn't deviate much from what you'd
expect of standard open source postgres
while Ali DB's performance makes it a
good fit for even your top tier
workloads more info pinned in the
comments
[Music]